hello if the Internet I'm Gavin damn
where the slow mo guys
and as usual Dan we're about to make a
right mess was a gogit challenged us to
do whatever it takes to get every last
drop of go get out of one of these tubes
which honestly very easy nailed it
so if you like the video please feel
wait no that's not the video obviously I
mean well one is too easy okay we'll
just just escalate it a thousand tubes
of doget all in one go empty em all
right yeah thankfully we have DIY expert
and Goga enthusiast Bob Vila who's got
an immense delivery for us it's a
thousand show hey guys I'm not even
gonna ask what you're getting into
well I think you're gonna need these
whatever happens and probably for the
best get to safety life safety your mile
away
okay thanks Bob tonight 10:00 on the pun
there like it alright let's load this up
Daniel okay oh all right here we go
I think you should be full clothes you
should be there here what will aim
everything just point the tubes this way
the go goes this way alright a few days
I always like it when a company wants us
to show off their products by destroying
it Oh stay away from this alright anyone
give us a little test of our
quick-release system here it works
before we get out there pull the safety
pin out and I've got this cord here give
this a Yank flip it works
ha ha how it works that is gonna go down
like it well like a ton yeah let's get
their weight in okay raise her up guy
min yep yeah okay okay become it yeah
oh good technique are using it yeah
using it all right
breehn up yep that's out that's down
give me the up signal please up signal
thank you okay yeah go give me the
signal what are you doing with your life
right your signal I look at
all right good Tech is that all right
Dan thoughts I'm kind of scared kind of
scared by kinda I mean very scared
you're very close to that okay you ready
yeah man
hmm well I'm bounced yeah
so it looks to me if I we need to put
last I think maybe if we just do like a
thin covering yeah so we got less go get
yeah we got a heavier block and it's
higher up and it's scarier right three
two one pull I mean it's not the most
efficient way over easier go go I
definitely got some in my mouth there ha
ha ha oh man I am covered
well Dan I would say my prediction at
the beginning of the video is absolutely
correct we did indeed make a right mess
of me yeah you're fine
look it well it's ridiculous Schlemmer
goes with you obviously standard you
hopefully you enjoyed that video you can
get involved yourself by showing us your
best efforts to get all the go get out
of the tube
send your slo-moes to the link in the
description cheers for watching you can
follow us on twitter you can also buy
one of our shirts
once again you definitely don't want
down it's caked but we have some fresh
clean ones for you to purchase a poster
you see it these are massive mugs on a
poster i don't off oh you're getting
there in that one so if you want dan and
i up on your wall so I'm just looking at
you really close up get a poster for
sure